- On this episode,
I talk about pressure, comedians,
golf and Presidents.
You ask questions and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and you're watching and listening
to the #AskGaryVee Show,
episode number 33.
Fun fact about the number 33,
that is the number of my favorite
all-time basketball player, Patrick Ewing.
- [Voiceover] Mike asks,
"We have high school kids working
"to get recruited and play college golf.
"Any suggestions on social responsibility
"on social media?"
- Mike, thanks for the question.
You know, very honestly,
and I don't want to diss you,
because you're watching my show
and I appreciate you and I know
you're coming from such a good place,
so it hurts me to make this statement.
But, that's an old man question.
And what I mean by that is,
there is a real lack of understanding
'cause I've been really
paying attention to this,
and I'm sure ancedotally,
you can give me a story of a kid
who put up a picture on Facebook
of him like throwing up at a party
and he lost his scholarship,
and I respect that.
But, as of every second,
by the time I'm done with this episode,
less people will care about those things
than they did when I started it.
Remember the conversation
4 years ago, everyone,
where like, "Don't put up pictures
"of beer pong on your Facebook,
"because you won't get into college."?
That is ludicrous conversation.
There is a small 1% of people
that live in this idealistic world
where they put people to a standard
that is not realistic and
they're so out of touch.
And if you want to go play golf
at one of those schools,
then you have to play in that realm.
But, I would tell you that I would
far be more concerned,
and I believe this is the sentiment
and kind of the movement of educators,
businesses and even athletic departments
of a kid that his entire social media
is so orchestrated and so refined
that I'd be worried if,
can he make that 11 foot putt
in a big spot if he's
that kind of personality?
And so, I would tell you
to worry less about that,
and worry less about coming on the show
and getting the tactics of like,
"Make sure you double
check before you this,"
or, "Never put a picture of this."
That's tactics.
Instill religion, my friend.
If you've got these high school kids
and they're listening to you,
teach them and build the foundations
of being a good human being.
That will get them through
a lot more stuff
and plenty of good human beings
have done a stupid thing for four seconds,
and one could say that ruined their lives,
I disagree.
- [Voiceover] Paul asks,
"We get like five views on our video,
"three of them being from us.
"How do very new and small channels
"gain a following when
people don't interact?"
- Paul, nice ratio on your viewership
because from Wine Library TV
I had a similar thing and it was
my grandma and mom,
so, I know that world.
The reason I was able to build up my
channel back in the day
and now as well,
though I have a bigger base now
and you can argue with that,
is the quality of the output, right?
I mean, at the end of the day,
how are you gonna find traction?
There's two ways.
One, you can put out great content,
that's what I do.
Two, and I don't know
if that's what you do,
maybe you stink,
so we need to talk about that.
Two, you need to biz dev.
Show this man.
Right, so,
I've done all my biz dev my entire career,
but, I'm getting stretched so thin.
So, Alex DS is gonna come in
and start doing biz dev.
So, when I see something from
a tweet from one of you,
and you want to distribute
this content on your page,
that used to go to my inbox
and it would disappear,
or the new WineLibrary.com
and there's wine content there,
and I want to get that distributed
'cause you have a food blog,
and you'd hit me up on Twitter,
that would get passed on.
But now, he can capture that and biz dev.
So, it's about biz dev.
You now, don't have
anybody talking about you
'cause you have five views,
and all those things.
But you need to biz dev in reverse.
I've been lucky enough to have
a 20 year well-executed successful career,
so it comes to me, I
deserve it. It's capitalism.
You have not done that yet,
but you will, hopefully.
I want you to. I want to
look back at this video
and be excited that you did.
When I didn't have that,
I had to biz dev.
When Wine Library was
Shopper's Discount Liquors
and nobody gave a crap,
I walked around the neighborhood
and knocked on restaurant doors and said,
"Can you put these flyers on your counter,
"for a 20% off coupon
by the case of wine?"
I hustled.
You, my friend, need to hustle.
Number one, the variable
is your creative.
No matter how much you hustle
and sell and put out flyers, Steve,
and put out flyers.
Podcast listeners, that was Steve
playing something in the background,
I apologize, he just
doesn't have any manners.
I was on a big point too, Steve.
No matter how hard I hustle,
and put out flyers and made it happen.
When people came to Wine Library,
if we didn't have a good selection,
if we didn't get good prices,
if we didn't have good
customer service, we lost.
So, the two variables are,
can you biz dev,
can you make it happen or
are you willing to hustle?
Do you realize that we can't be romantic,
that, we're just gonna
put out an awesome show
and it's all gonna work out.
Bullshit.
What needs to happen is you have
to put out an awesome show
and hustle your face off 15 hours a day
to get people to care.
That's very different
than spamming people.
than going on Twitter
and be like, "Watch our show,
"watch our show, watch our show."
Even in a world where you don't
have a huge audience,
you have a way to bring value to somebody.
If you can figure out how to do that,
and then leverage that value
for them to give you what you want
which is exposure, you will win.
It blows my mind how many people
email me every single day saying,
"Gary, can you tweet about my show?"
In a world where I'm such a hustler
and such a biz dev guy,
and such a wanter to give
to people on the rise,
and none of them ask
what they can do for me,
or do something for me.
Like, where's that video,
where's your video show
saying "Hey, we want to do like
"five custom GaryVee videos."
In our world, we'll give 'em to you,
you can use them as assets
and then maybe you can give us some love.
No, because people think about themselves
and how do I get views.
And what the whole world is predicated on
when you're doing biz dev is,
can I give that person
51% of the value
of the situation.
Because if I do, then they'll say yes
and then I can get 49% of the value,
and that's what I do, day in and day out,
and day in and day out.
And that's why I continue to win
in a world where people
want 100% of the value.
You wanted this question answered
'cause you wanted an answer
and you were hoping that you
could get on this show
and get the exposure,
right, for your channel.
You know what?
I'm gonna be a good guy,
DRock link it up, there it is.
Can't you do stuff
within the YouTube world?
There you go, you got some views.
Now, bring some value.
- [Voiceover] Thousand asks,
"Who is your favorite comedian?"
- Thousand Moments, let me give
you that answer, but before I do, Steve,
'cause I love you so much,
show him, show him.
Tell everybody what you just said
before we did the question,
because, you had a good rationale
for ruining the show's audio.
- The noise that I made
during the last episode
was because I was pulling
up Paul's YouTube channel,
which is a Minecraft channel
by the way, so, well done.
- Cool.
Now that I found out
it's a Minecraft channel,
you may want to change that up
because that is one competitive space.
Alright, my favorite comedian of all time.
I would probably say that it is
a tie, because I wanna give--
It's a three-way tie
between Richard Pryor,
Eddie Murphy and Chris Rock.
And now, if you go back and watch
all of my keynotes and watch its cadence,
you may see where the
influence comes from.
- [Voiceover] Nasir asks,
"Sometimes my passion
is seen as aggression.
"How do I walk the line?
"Do I change to someone more passive?"
- Nasir?
Nasir, first of all,
don't change for anybody.
Now,
finding that balance of grace
and having that tact to be
consumable is a process.
I, somewhere around eighth grade
into sophomore year,
didn't hit the right tone anymore.
I was too intense for my classmates,
and I could taste it 'cause I have empathy
and kind of self-awareness,
and it's an ongoing process.
Like, you know, for example,
my keynotes are interesting,
I just referenced them.
I'm actually evolving
that cadence throughout
the conversation of the tone,
'cause I'm reacting to the body language
of everybody else.
It's not about how do
you become more passive,
'cause I'd hate to suck
the passion out of you
which is a huge variable to success.
Controlling it and people saying,
"You're just a little too much."
I have a feeling that that's predicated
on you caring too much for it
to be valuable for you.
I'm gonna say that again for everybody.
The only reason I think
that I'm able to pull off this
is because there's a healthy balance
of caring about you.
When you care more about your audience
than what you have to say,
you start winning, right?
When you care more about
your global audience
listening or watching
and it's not about the 15 minutes
of what am I gonna get out of it,
then sure, in a right hook world
it's always there.
Let me actually use this question
to define something that I don't think
I talked about in the book.
I live in a world of
jab, jab, jab, right hook.
Let me tell you two
interesting things of that.
I don't necessarily feel that I ever have
to throw a right hook
and I don't expect the
need to throw a right hook
based on my jabs in micro levels.
At the holistic level, I do.
Also, there's another part that
we never talk about, is there?
Which is, what happens when
the right hook doesn't land?
I'm actually not disappointed.
What happens when I do all awesome stuff
for these guys or anybody else?
I don't have any expectation that they're
gonna do something
awesome for me in return.
Eliminating that lack of expectation
opens up a world of where you can provide.
So, based on your question,
based on my intuition,
my vibe on this question,
it has a whole lot to do
with you caring more about them,
the people that are judging you,
they're telling you to chill out.
They're telling you that because,
not about your passion,
because, take it from me
and many other people,
people love passion.
They don't like selfish passion.
I'm on f*king fire.
(laughing)
- [Voiceover] Chris asks,
"If it wasn't for the 14th amendment,
"would you run for President?"
- Chris has a tremendous question
to end the show.
The answer is I would run for President.
It's really funny.
And the reason I'm laughing about
this question is Chris, you've set me up
to expose a dark part of me,
which is the selfish part of me,
'cause we all have it.
The singular reason that I'm probably not
already having a serious eye on politics
is because I can't be President,
and I am not willing to as a human being,
play a game that I can't be
the ultimate winner of.
And many of you are gonna leave comments
on the YouTube channel
or hit me up on Twitter,
you podcasters and say,
"That is not noble,
"you could be a governor and make
"a huge impact or a congressman
"or mayor or you know."
And I understand that.
But, that's not what I want.
I'm selfish about that.
And so, yes, if they changed,
if Schwarzenegger followed through
on what I wish he could have done,
but he couldn't,
if somebody comes along or they change it,
not in the current environment, clearly,
I would put myself into that game,
because, I probably pride myself on
the singular thing that I think
when things are a worst, I'm best.
I eat pressure for breakfast.
I love it, I need it,
it's why I love HR. it's
the ultimate pressure,
people hate that kind of pressure.
So, if you look at the hairlines
and the color of the hair of Presidents,
of when they start to
when they're finished,
they looked like they aged 60 years.
I'm already aging with my hair,
I want it all gone.
I just can't play that game.
And so the answer very
simply is, yes I would.
And that leads me into the question
of the day for everybody.
I just want to thank everybody
for watching episode 33,
I think we're on a roll here,
I'm enjoying it.
Question of the day, who is your--
Ah, I was gonna go with
who is your favorite President.
But, I gotta be honest with you.
The notion of getting into that politics
with this community that
is so f*king awesome,
you're gonna beep that,
makes me not want to ask that.
So, may question of the day instead is,
I'm in a very serious candy theme,
just show it, I just looked at it.
By the way, when we're
talking about improv,
this is how these questions get,
if you ever wondered how they come,
there is no strategy with
the question of the day.
What is your favorite candy?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
- [DRock] You're what?
- No, you're not getting it.
(laughing)
- [DRock] Too bad I did.
- Either you're gonna be ready
or you're not getting sh*t DRock.
There is no second time.
Ready?
- [DRock] Yep.
Oh crap, wait, subscribe!
I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many
right hooks in social so, subscribe.